orlane alexiens alexandre les autres ne
raterait cette répétition pour rien au
monde le théâtre ils se sont portés
volontaires pour en faire ici au collège
bourmaud tout est parti d'une idée du
professeur d'histoire qui comme chaque
année participent avec des collégiens
concours proposé par l'académie de la
réunion sur l'esclavagé les abolitions
et la traite
au delà de sa participation au concours
nous nous avons vu faire une pièce de
théâtre qui va durer on espère entre 45
minutes et une heure qui racontera
l'histoire donc de 7,7 esclaves qui
devient affranchi qui s'appelle la net
qui prend le nom doivent être qu'eric en
1948 ainsi débute ce retour dans le
passé qui à la période de l'esclavagisme
et et la vie de la nec planète cet
esclave affranchi qui fait le choix de
rester avec sa maîtresse alors que
l'abolition de l'esclavagé proclamé
moine est libre pose la question de
cette soi-disante liberté qui s'inscrit
dans les textes mais qui ne s'appliquent
pas dans les filles une répétition qui
débute par des exercices d'échauffement
avec le professeur de théâtre on fait
simplement ça je la touche quelque part
elle me touche quelque part je la
retouche quelque part elmer touche
quelque part on est passés par des
exercices d'échauffement à au début de
chaque séance systématiquement pour être
dans le jeu et puis pour pour aussi
mettre en place un certain nombre de
règles et
et c'est quand même un super groupe
parce qu'en fait ils sont tellement
motivés parce qu'ici parce qu'ils
veulent faire à la fin de l'année pour
jouer le rôle de nanette deux
comédiennes orlan et nous et c'est le
personnage principal et comme c'est une
esclave bain sur un canal travaillais
déjà pour moi c'est important donc on
comprend un peu dans quel milieu lg 18
on s'amuse on est avec nos camarades on
apprend des choses sur les sparages sur
des gens qui ont vécu ça des collégiens
qui se glisse dans la peau de leur
personnage après avoir travailler
l'écriture en cédant des documents des
archives départementales
nous sommes en 1848 alexandre maire de
saint-leu annonce annan est qu elle est
libre
ah c'est toi bonjour l'aneth on connaît
moins commun et la wii ne t'inquiète pas
j'aurai besoin d'informations voir
écrire tonnac d'affranchissement dans la
scène du joueur on libère une esclave
nanet qu'eric et
on l'a déclaré libre même vol que
alexandre fait ce qu'elle fait dans une
différentes scènes et de là on parle de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé qui va venir
dans le futur mais qui n'est pas encore
arrivé
dans cette pièce qui sera jouée en juin
outre le rôle central de nanette
l'histoire de sa propriétaire je trouve
que c'est très enrichissant et c'est
bien de savoir ce qui s'est passé avant
et j'aime bien faire du théâtre nanet
l'histoire d'une esclave qui même sans
les chaînes ne retrouvera jamais sa
liberté elle mourra en 1861 à 80 ans sur
la propriété de la fille de sa maîtresse
nanet qui était la soeur des leaders de
la révolte de saint leu en 1911 et lee
et ses deux frères qui avaient été
condamnées à mort et décapité
parce qu'il revendiquait justement cette
semaine liberté oui jacques les thèmes
ombale frère jacques la paix pour ce que
vers l'a fait